he's a plague Tony he invades planets he
takes what he wants he wipes out half
the population he has the power and
space stones that already makes him the
strongest creature in the whole universe
if he gets his hands on all six dollars
Tony he could destroy life on a scale
hitherto undreamed happy infinity war
week everybody this is gonna be my post
credit scene video hopefully you've had
a chance to see the movie but obviously
spoiler warning if you have not seen it
yet we will be going into specifics of
Marvel's The Empire Strikes Back so if
you are brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's gonna be a lot of
Avengers for talk that we'll do in the
next couple of weeks and there's a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
that I'll explain at the end of the
video we make a lot of jokes about how
it feels like Marvel was going for their
version of Empire Strikes Back with this
movie I think they were largely
successful in that I'll talk about it a
little bit more during my spoiler review
but remember the Obi one scene after the
Death Star blows up Alderaan are you
alright I felt a great disturbance in
the force as if millions of voices
suddenly cried out in terror suddenly
silenced if your big comic book ban you
probably noticed immediately what they
did with Thanos quests in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline that post-credits
scene is effectively in overlap it's a
twist on a Nick Fury moment from the
beginning of the Infinity Gauntlet
literally within the first 15 pages of
that storyline so what happens is is
Nick Fury and Maria hill are standing on
a street corner with sirens going off
everywhere everyone's screaming there's
lots of car crashes happening you hear a
helicopter Carine by and crash without a
pilot in it my only thought there was
them doing a Thanos copter Easter Egg
Nick Fury gets really pissed off like he
has a sense for what's going on he
starts to see people turning to ash
around him pulls his phone out starts to
dial and starts to drop an f-bomb but
right before he can drop the f-bomb
he turns to ash - then the camera zooms
in on his phone and you see Captain
Marvel symbol so he's calling in
reinforcements for Avengers 4 there are
two big reasons why they chose this
particular post-credit scene when you
could have done anything like you could
actually jump to Captain Marvel but
number one I think that they wanted to
tease the idea of Captain Marvel
not completely giving everything away
what our costume looks like what her
powers look like because we're gonna get
the Captain Marvel movie right before
Avengers 4 comes out that'll explain all
that she's gonna be a huge character
during Avengers 4 so they want some
connective tissue between that character
in between these two parts of infinity
War part 1 in part to whatever part 2 is
going to be called the second big reason
why they chose Nick Fury is because he's
going to be a big character during the
Captain Marvel movie which will be set
in the past during the 90s so he is the
connective tissue between Captain Marvel
Avengers infinity war in Avengers 4 the
only people that really get left out in
the cold air or ant-man the wasp because
they have a movie that's coming out in a
couple months this summer that is
confirmed to be happening before the
events of infinity war now post-civil
war but before infinity war what will
happen is is I'll do a separate video
explaining that timeline after more
people have a chance to see the movie
there'll be plenty of Avengers for
videos but effectively what they're
doing with the end of infinity war is
ending with the very beginning the intro
to the Infinity Gauntlet storyline what
happens at the beginning of that is a
Thanos just starts the story the opening
pages with the completed Infinity
Gauntlet in Mephisto is standing there
with them just marveling at his
achievement just to make up Marvel pun
you're like a god now so you remember
during comic book Infinity Gauntlet he
assembled the gauntlet to erase half of
all life for death who felt like there
was just too much life it needed to be
balanced standing victorious he's hoping
to have one deaths affections at
completing the task but then realizes oh
how silly of me how inconsiderate
I haven't actually completed the task as
you requested in thinking that this will
just completely when death over who
doesn't care about him at all she's just
standing there blank face like okay
let's get this on on any minute now
you'll finish so I can go back to my own
devices and without any grand speech or
anything like that just reaches the
gauntlet up into the sky then probably
the best reaction to this is Mephisto
who's probably only here so that he can
have this reaction whispering he's
really going to do it like even Mephisto
doesn't believe that Thanos going to
wipe out half of all life in the
universe and snaps his fingers and
that's when you get that scene with
everybody noticing half of all the
people on the street disappearing
when you reread that storyline which I
would recommend that you do if you
haven't recently the opening pages also
deal with Silver Surfer in the Bruce
Banner role warning dr. strange about
the coming of Thanos Silver Surfer is
effectively recapping the events of the
Pharaoh's quest storyline and they don't
really need to do that with infinity war
that's why they have that truncated
Bruce Banner scene at the beginning of
the movie because most people have been
rewatching the Marvel films you don't
need a complete explainer you just need
the T up for people that are walking
into this fresh I think most of us were
expecting them to end the movie on a
moment like this because a long time ago
most of us comic book fans when they
said with the plot of infinity war would
be Thanos collecting all the gems like a
smash-and-grab heist film we're like oh
they're doing Thanos quest because
that's what happens during the Thanos
quest storyline meaning that maybe
they'll do the Infinity Gauntlet comic
book for Avengers 4 or some version of
that so if you've seen infinity war
obviously you know that they changed the
plot of Thanos quest a lot they even
jumped ahead and borrowed a couple
moments from later in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline like with Gamora and
nebula with them trying to get the
gauntlet off of his hand so there's a
lot of mixing and matching but in the
comic book version of this the people
that disappear are actually Hawkeye
Cersei mary jane wong mentor of titan
Thanos's father who's dead during the
course of this movie half of the scroll
Empire but what these opening pages do
is they just give you this moment that
is effectively the end of infinity war
where most of the main characters of the
Infinity Saga notice people disappearing
all over the place there's even a
shout-out to a character named Charlie
when spider-man is noticing all these
people in Times Square disappearing but
you can kind of see why I use that
obi-wan scene because you have
spider-man here serving is that sort of
voiceover role narrating for everyone
there was no ominous warning not one
storm cloud heavenly voice nor any of
the kind of things that would accompany
such a cataclysmic event nothing just
half the people down in Times Square
merely vanished at first thought I
thought I was losing my mind flipping
out who or what could have done this had
only Times Square been affected or was
this happening all over the city then it
hit me Mary Jane you know like he
screams Mary Jane he goes running off to
try and find out what happened to her I
know there's gonna be all kinds of
questions about
they picked the specific characters to
die that died at the end of the movie
you like why is Captain America sitting
here where vision and black panther end
up turning you to ash because they're
big characters - why does spider-man
turn to ash you kind of see what they're
doing with Avengers 4 though like you
have Captain Marvel that's coming in
because of that post-credit scene but
it's mostly the original Avengers that
survive and they kill off all the newer
characters not everybody because there's
some Guardians representation there
phase 2 technically they're not oh gee
they didn't debut till after that first
Avengers movie but I think they just
want some representation from that
separate space-based storyline so that's
probably why the writers let Star Lord
survive so that you just have some
representation from that group of
characters because you've already seen a
bunch of them die so effectively it's
the original Avengers versus Thanos at
the beginning of Avengers 4 now things
could change over the course of that
we've seen some behind-the-scenes
pictures of them barfing and looking
back to the original events of the first
Avengers movie with Captain America
wearing his old costume you have to
remember that they gave Thanos the time
gem so this isn't them travelling back
in time but we'll talk more about
potential plot lines and things that
they could pull from the comics for
Avengers 4 in separate videos leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
what'll happen next is is I'll post my
spoiler review for infinity war Friday
morning then the rest of the weekend
will be Avengers videos just based on
what people want to talk about so be
sure to leave your suggestions in the
comments below it all you have to do to
enter that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video but click here for my
non-spoilery infinity war review and
click here for that brand-new Deadpool
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]